[Applause]
for each of the nominees for best
production design
it was a dream and journey that wasn't
always clear
growing up kathy lucas loved movies but
couldn't quite figure out where she fit
into making them
as a young architecture student nathan
crowley
had no idea he could ever be a part of
the film industry but tonight
they are both nominated for tenet
donald graham burt spent the early part
of his career sweeping floors as an
onset janitor jan pascal was a puppet
master
on mr rogers neighborhood we recognize
their incredible work tonight
on bank and as fate would have it
jan pascal would later hire mark riker
as an intern
which put him on the road to making ma
rainey's black bottom alongside
brilliant set decorators diana stalton
and karen o'hara
now i wonder mark uh were you
thinking about anything when you were
getting jan's coffee i mean like did you
see that coming
just a thought peter francis trained for
many years as a landscape
architect kathy featherstone couldn't
stop thinking about
how to construct one-eyed willie's ship
after watching the goonies as a kid
so she started building sets and
designing costumes for school plays just
before she teamed up with peter
on the father and finally david crank
landed in motion picture design after
working in theater for 10 years
elizabeth keenan worked in advertising
for 15 years before hopping on a plane
to the czech republic to secure her
first set
decorating job they are both nominated
tonight
for news of the world
and the oscar goes to
bank
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
sex
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a long way down here
first of all thank you to david fincher
sean schafen and don burt for trusting
me with this amazing project
i i'm just it was such an honor to work
with such an amazing group of people
thank you to my crew who worked their
tails off on this
just to make it right and you know
when i was young i never realized that
this was a career that was even a
possibility
there were so many people that helped me
along the way
and guided me and i'm so grateful to all
of them
and especially to my wife louise who
inspires me every day
thank you so much
you